un deuxième acte dramatique en à peine
deux semaines après la mort de samuel
pâtit bah oui et probablement un
troisième dans quelque temps parce que
on voit bien que depuis 2015
au gré à la fois de de l'actualité
internationale et de la réponse ou des
éléments de réponse que la france
apporte et au gré de la vie finalement
de la delà de la société française et
des événements qui se produisent dans
cette société
on l'a vu il ya quinze jours ou trois
semaines pour samuel pâtit
c'était à l'occasion de la parution des
caricatures de charlie hebdo qui
finalement est un non événement en
france parce que publier des caricatures
c'est quelque chose qui se fait
constamment mais qui est pris à coeur
par une partie de la population
musulmane et d'un chaque fois ça re
créer des tensions religieuses et donc
parmi les personnes qui sont concernées
qui sont agacés excité énervé hystériser
part c'est par ces phénomènes là on a
une frange extrêmement dangereuse
terroristes qui n'hésitent pas à passer
à l'acte des personnes alors j'attends
avec vraiment grande impatience de
connaître l'identité et le profil de
l'assaillant mais on a finalement deux
types de profils aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
bien identifiés le numéro un c'est le
type meira ou coulibaly donc des
personnes qui en cours ou d'autres mêmes
qui ont grandi en france et qui passent
à l'acte des personnes qui ont vécu en
france qui connaissent nos institutions
dont on pourrait penser qu'elles sont
intégrées alors qu'elles ne le sont pas
puis second profil c'est le pakistanais
dont on a beaucoup parlé au moment du
deuxième attentat au hachoir devant les
locaux charlie-hebdo ou
celui qui a décapité samuel pâtit le
tchétchène et à ce moment là c'est des
personnes qui rentrent sur notre
territoire soit sous de faux prétextes
soit avec une intention potentiellement
malveillante et qui ne sont pas bloquées
parce que nous avons des règles de
migratoires qui sont laxistes et donc à
travers le flux massif de personnes qui
rend très bien se loger ces individus
qui potentiellement peuvent attenter à
la vie des français donc aujourd'hui
j'attends de savoir quel type de profil
le l'assaillant revêt mais on sait déjà
que ça va probablement s'inscrire dans
un de ces deux profils là et donc
forcément les niçois prend un premier
titre mais les français de façon plus
générale se demande mais quand est ce
que réellement ça va s'arrêter ou alors
quand est-ce que cette guerre dont on
nous parle depuis maintenant 2015 depuis
que manuel valls a déclaré la guerre au
terrorisme quand est ce que cette guerre
va commencer c'est à dire quand est ce
que la france va commencer à répondre
c'est à dire que dans une guerre
normalement les deux assaillants
combattent
on a l'impression que la france encaisse
mais qu'elle ne répond jamais